live shows are no no new thing in your
world so what was it like to watch all
the talent and their nerves on the first
live show actually funny enough I felt
like everybody was super confident and
comfortable and when they came out I
feel like they just were like this is
where I'm supposed to be this is my
moment and so to be able to witness that
and be a part of it it's super special I
mean it's it's unbelievable what is it
like for you to know that your face is
getting the meme treatment of your
reactions like that you know the
reactions we watch the show tonight the
reaction shots of you are incredible
every action shot the guys getting the
cucumber like sawed down and your face
is like oh my gosh I mean I was
literally sitting there talking to
Gabrielle and I was like there are so
many innuendos so it could be saying
right now but not appropriate for
broadcast television but yeah I mean
insane this is the best I don't even
want to call it a job because the job
feels like work this is like the best
gift I could ever have I mean I get to
literally be a part of helping people's
dreams come true and I get to watch them
and be entertained all night it's
amazing your body body on this cover
it's I saw it and I was like I need to
go to the gym like instantly how hard
did you train to get ready and what do
you make of all the reaction around it
you know it's funny I I purposefully
obviously I worked out but I worked out
like I normally do I didn't want to do
anything different than what I have been
doing because the whole purpose of this
specific issue was about delayering all
the the you know the survival tactics or
the like I have to be perfect things
that we place on ourselves or that we
feel like people place on us and so it
was like no I just I want to feel
whether I'm soft or ripped or whatever
it is I just want to feel like me and
and that was I'm so proud of those
photos there's nothing sexualized about
them it's super strong it's powerful
it's not like I'm a fighter but it's
also not like I'm covering up
there's something just I don't know I'm
really proud of them and look at the fam
thing cuz I know you come from sort of a
more of a conservative background so
like Derek what did Derek think because
I went to my family reunion right after
this all came out and I was like alright
let's see what the family has to say and
honestly it just goes to show that like
with all of our different backgrounds
and our different beliefs religiously or
politically or whatever it might be the
common denominator is love and support
and understanding and listening and what
did Brooks think not only of the photo
but the article is yeah I mean you're
giving people look into the real soul of
you I think my husband is the most
supportive person ever and you know we
talk about it all the time
if if that was not the case then we
would have a very different really like
relationship but the reason why our
relationship works is because we're
completely raw and open and exposed and
I think that you know I think there's
nothing look at the end of the day
people are going to take whatever
headlines they want to take and they did
and that's totally fine and I and I get
that but at the end of the day like if I
feel like I have something to hide in
any sense then that's not me being
totally just like open and I know I'm in
the entertainment business and it's like
a whole thing but I mean we're living in
a time when I don't know why not are you
ready I don't have an answer guys I just
it just is ready for people now to be
sort of looking at your relationship
through this magnifying glass though
because I think when you start to open
up people want more and more and more of
you I mean yeah obviously the tonight
people are asking those questions and
the good news is I am an open book so
ask away and I'll tell you what I want
to tell you
but I'm what I'm I don't know life is
just life and relationships or
relationships and people can deem them
whatever they want to be but I think as
long as you know what it is nothing else
matters